[Music]
[Applause]
for Chase Daniel who does an awesome job
in really everything he does you know
quarterbacks have such an advantage
breaking down some of this stuff I hate
them they have advantage in every aspect
of life and Chase is doing the same
thing with his Terrific show on YouTube
Chase it's Ross Tucker man good to see
you thanks for coming on the show yeah
thanks for having me man I appreciate it
and it's hilarious so I saw the Tweet
the unman Ubers are real because like we
we go to Phoenix we we're home based in
San Diego and we go to Phoenix once or
twice a year to play golf because best
golf in the world in my opinion over
there and um dude I've seen a few of
them but you look and there's no one
driving there's no one in the front seat
and there's like three people in the
back seat and oh by the way it's like
$6 to go to the airport so they're
taking over it's just it's creepy as all
get out though man like I like I can't I
don't trust
like you see all these problems that
that Tesla's having with these
autopilots like unmanned vehicles I
don't know but yeah that that was it's
weird so so wait so so two interesting
things there Chase so number one I never
thought about that but of course they
would be a lot cheaper because you don't
have to pay the person so that makes
sense way cheaper
secondly I agree that it's weird but
then I think about how many people are
driving that probably shouldn't be
driving
and I think I don't know maybe I'd
rather have a
computer than some of these people that
are like not paying attention or might
not be the brightest
bulbs yeah I I mean I agree with that
it's just it's just weird to see unman
vehicle like I'm with you I'm not ready
for it I'm Pro technology but I'm just
I'm just not ready for it all right so
what you are ready is to break down week
18 so here's the first question did you
ever start one of these games did you
ever start one of these you know we
we're resting the starters so you get
the last start of the Year games
yeah two two actually it's wild my first
start
ever um was against the San Diego
Chargers it was
2013 I think it was our first year Andy
Reid Chiefs we had locked up like the
five seed I don't think we could have
gone e either like higher or lower
so it was the game I don't know if you
remember but it was the game where like
I think we were like 10 and five and the
Chargers were nine and like four nine
and five something like something crazy
they had to win to get into the playoffs
so they they were they were playing
everybody and we literally sat as many
people as possible for the Chiefs we
ended up um kicking a 40-yard field goal
with no time to win the game the kicker
missed it we went to overtime and they
actually beat us in overtime on this
like crazy fourth and 15 play uh um to
actually get into the playoffs so it was
it was cool to go into to San Diego and
almost beat Philip Rivers and the
Chargers starters when I was there so it
was interesting and that's what a lot of
these people understand like like I got
a graphic from minl Network sent to me
um about all the backup quarterbacks
that are going and I sent a tweet out I
was like hey this is electric and it was
like blae Gabbert vers Easton stick and
look those it it's just like I actually
enjoy it because it's a great
opportunity for people in guys who have
been backup quarterbacks um to show what
they got and this game to these guys
means a lot now to fans it might not
mean so much but it's a good opportunity
for for them to show not only themselves
but their teammates and their teams and
and people around the world like hey you
you belong here right because anytime
you get an opportunity to start like in
the NFL there's only 32 jobs right so um
to be able to get one of those On Any
Given Sunday it's it's a pretty cool
cool thing and I was saying earlier in
the show Chase and I think it's more for
it's any position but more for
quarterback than other positions do you
guys have like an equation because I'm
buddies with some backup quarterbacks
like Chad henn's from my hometown right
and I'm convinced right if you start one
game and play well that adds like like
you're good for the next two years like
you like you start one game you play
well three years yeah you get two or
three years out of that unless unless
you have to go in again in between and
play back but like it I mean is there
like a math equation but you guys know
that that's how it works well you you
you realize like it's this league is
like it's there's some bad quarterback
play like let's just be honest and so
when somebody comes in like a jake
Browning or like I wouldn't even put
gner mchu as a backup because he's been
a starter but what gner menchu's done to
be able to have the Colts in a playing
game this year he was brought into
Mentor Anthony Richardson in the second
game of the year he's playing the entire
year so I think teams are going to put
way more of a value on backup
quarterbacks but yeah all it takes I
mean look you're not only playing these
guys that are playing this this week all
the backups they're not just playing for
their team because a lot of these guys
are in short-term contracts they're
playing for 31 other teams they're
putting their their their stuff on tape
so when the backup quarterback and the
starting quarterback Carousel goes round
and round like it does every off season
some of these guys who play well in this
last game they're going to have a spot
and I think and what I'm hearing is like
teams are going to put more of an
emphasis on backup quarterback because
look at this year right like there's
been so many different quarterbacks 70s
something quarterbacks to play this year
and so I think you not only need a
number one but teams are going to spend
to be able to get a number two and those
number twos at the top of the list
they're going to go fast and they're
going to go for a lot of money over $5
million um on a yearly salary but it's
worth it for teams like like the Bengals
like they didn't make the playoffs but
to have Jake Brown no one in the right
mind thought Jake Browning was going to
play and play well and put them in a
position to even remotely have a shot at
the playoffs and look at what he's done
this year he's made himself a lot of
money and and extended his career at
least three years in my opinion talking
with longtime NFL quarterback Chase
Daniel here on The Dan Patrick Show Ross
Tucker filling in for Dan on a meat
Friday check out the Chase Daniel show
on YouTube it is fantastic so here's my
question about CJ Stroud and Bryce Young
right I don't really remember Chase many
people saying that they likeed stad more
than young there might be somebody out
there that said it but most people the
consensus was young ones troud to and
Lovey Smith blew it for the Texans
because he won that last game last year
what did we miss about both these guys
and I'm not I'm not right in their
careers yet it's only year one I get it
but man stoud looks really good and and
young really does not what did we miss
what what did all the EV valuators Miss
well I think at the end of the day like
with CJ right the whole thing is like
the testing and is he smart is he like I
hate when media members especially and
even teams put any emphasis at all on
like you're taking a test that has
nothing to do with football okay like
just go and meet with the guy if you
think if you want to get an opportunity
on how he how he processes things or how
when you get onto the field it's
completely different and and to be
honest i' I always liked CJ strout and I
agree that like in college Bryce young
had a better uh a better career but I I
wasn't like you could talk me out of
like Bryce young versus CJ St like I
thought CJ St had a little bit of a
higher ceiling um and you know all these
attacks on character for for CJ St like
like I was talking with the Houston
Texans coaching staff before the draft
like hey we'll be happy with either and
we think we're going to get CJ and we're
actually pumped because CJ in my opinion
he's built like an NFL quarterback I
didn't real realized like when I put on
the film of CJ in the NFL and I broke
him down every single week this this
year because he's fun to watch I didn't
realize how quick of a release he had
how well he processed stuff how good of
a leader he was talking with the
coaching staff and that's a big deal and
when you go over to the other side of um
the Spectrum and you go to um Bryce
Young
I just think like it's not he's not you
look at the Players around him I'm
trying to say this in in a nice way
because I I I got players and and people
on that team um The Players around him
just they're not as as good as the
players around CJ Stout if that makes
sense so your quarterback is only as
good as The Playmakers you put around
you look at that offensive line for
Carolina like like Bryce has very little
time to throw and I don't think this
year is any indication on what he can be
in his career but you also have to sort
of build an offense around him just like
any other quarterback you got to put
pieces around him you got to put
receivers like everyone's just playing
man coverage against Carolina because
those receivers can't beat man coverage
and Bryce is having to hold on to the
ball a little bit longer these receivers
are getting hemmed up at the offensive
uh at the line of scrimmage and there's
nowhere to go with the football and so
he's having to try to make plays outside
of him and he just looks fragile man
like he looks like if he takes one more
hit he might not make it but I think if
you if David terer gets this higher
right in Carolina and I think you have
to go offensive mind like a Ben Johnson
that he's gonna have to overpay for or
something like that like I I think this
time next year you you're going to be
sitting here and saying wow okay yeah
maybe it was coaching maybe it was the
players around him that caused him to
not not have such a great season talking
with Chase Daniel here longtime NFL
quarterback host of The Chase Daniel
show on YouTube you see him on NFL
Network he's got a lot of stuff going in
the media now I see him with Trey Wingo
uh it's interesting Chase because you
said uh CJ stra built like an NFL
quarterback you know you're what 5'10
something like that oh I'm six foot come
on bro okay okay six foot but what but
you but you but you were but chase you
were one of the
original like short quarterbacks like
now it's like it's cool for Kyler Murray
and Baker Mayfield but when you were in
the league chase you might have been
like the only guy less than 6'2 when you
first my question is and you played Big
Time Texas High School Football like how
many times were you told you were too
short High School College NFL to have
the career you did I think I think
mainly the the biggest thing was the NFL
career because in high school like we
went 47 and one in three years at South
Carol and in Dallas and won two two uh
state championships lost a third state
championship by a point and we threw for
so many yards and touchdowns go I had I
had over 75 offers to go to college
ended up choosing Missouri set records
at Missouri so I don't know why it would
be any different at the next level but I
remember on draft night or draft day
like the third day my guy was like look
hey my agent was like Hey I just I just
don't think you're G to get drafted like
you're just not tall enough is what I'm
hearing I'm like I measured six foot and
an eighth at the combine I measured six
foot at the at at the um East West
Shrine like what do you mean like it
doesn't really matter and you see and
that was sort of the start you look at
like Russell Wilson Kyler Murray Bryce
young all these other guys who've had
success and obviously the number one guy
was Drew Brees right right at six foot
first ballot Hall of Famer and so it was
a little bit annoying to me because I'm
like I put my tape on the film and put
it on the field and you're going to tell
me that one thing outside of my control
is the reason why I'm not going to get
drafted and so I think I used that as a
chip on my shoulder not necessarily for
motivation but for a way to be like okay
I'm going to prove not people um like
wrong but the people who believed in me
I'm going to prove them right if that
makes sense that was my motivation not
really the doubters or anything else and
I turned it into a 14-year career and
and uh it's been it's it was it was a
fun career that's for sure so when
people uh Chase and you know a lot of
people talk about how much money you
made you know given how many games you
played or started does that bother you
or does it make you laugh or does it
make you proud you think it's hilarious
I I was SC your reaction yeah I think
it's hilarious I mean look look um you
know you are worth what somebody is
willing to pay you and I um prided
myself on being the hardest
worker at every single team I was on um
at helping the quarterbacks out uh the
starters out um I had a lot of offensive
coordinators two or three to get head
coaching jobs um and then I think once
you're in the league and you get and you
actually play I think I've started five
or six games and you play and you play
well it just extends your career we
talked about it and then I think you
become like okay he's the guy that can
come in and Mentor with Carson Wentz or
Mitch trabis or Justin Herbert or all
these guys and so it's kind of not your
fault it's kind of not your fault right
that your the starter didn't get H hurt
more often I mean you you easily could
have started like 30 or 40 games but the
starter like almost never got hurt I
know and in all in all the areas that I
was in and teams I was in that's the one
thing like the starter was abnormally
like healthy like the 2013 start I did
that I talked about we had already
locked up the fist seed 2014 Alex Smith
like busted his spleen open the week
before in Pittsburgh I I got two days
notice I was starting on Christmas and
then trabis gets hurt um in Chicago and
really those are the only starts and and
trabis came back so it wasn't like an
extended start so yeah I just um
starters in front of me just we uh we
healthy hey you mentioned Chicago last
one cuz I just did their game on Sunday
against the Falcons and they got a big
one against the Packers this Sunday how
do you feel about Fields I mean the
Bears have the number one pick man they
could get anybody Caleb Williams Drake
may do you would you draft somebody or
would you stick with Fields I do not
think that the Chicago Bears should
trade Justin fields and I've been very
very vocal on social media on my YouTube
channel on everything and and the and
the main reason is you just don't know
what you're getting in Caleb Williams
Drake mayor Michael pinnick Jr like you
have no clue you know what you have in
Justin fields and you know that the
ceiling is rising his stock is going up
and and every time that he stepped on
that field and the offensive game plan
that um Luke getsy has put together has
been something that he's liked to do and
what he does well unlike like the under
Center play action stuff that they were
doing early last year or even this year
you put them in a shotgun have them RPO
I think I think his decision uh making
and his processing has gotten a lot
faster that was the biggest thing I
wanted to see him and he's just he's
going up like I Justin Fields is going
to be a starting quarterback somewhere
next year and I could just imagine like
like I do a bunch of like uh hits on
like Chicago national sports radio and
it's a circus over there right now man
everyone's split I feel like the fans
want Fields but I can just imagine that
if the Chicago Bears were to pick a
quarterback at number one they're they
would trade Justin Fields I can't
imagine them keeping them together trade
Justin Fields And what if the fields
goes to the Las Vegas Raiders like
that's that's a good Lane spot or the
Atlanta Falcons and the first six games
of the year the Bears are struggling
because they've started the quarterback
clock over you know they have a good
defense but they're trying to get this
offense what is this quarterback new
quarterback like and Justin field six
games in is ball in has the Raiders at
4- two or the Falcons at 4- two like
could you imagine the explosion in
Chicago sports radio um there like
that's just what I think and look at the
end of the day Ryan
poles I guarantee you at the beginning
of the year he was probably thinking hey
we're probably going to take a
quarterback at number one if we end up
getting the pick that decision right now
is not so cut and dry and so he's
probably thinking like oh man now I got
a serious decision to make um the future
of the franchise is in my hands that's
why he got paid all these big bucks to
do it so I'll be interested to follow
his decision Chase thanks so much for
the time man really appreciate great
talk with you thanks guys there he is
Chase Daniel make sure you check out the
Chase Daniel show on YouTube